[Music]
all now we might have talked about this
one a while back uh it was about a
Danish artist who submitted empty frames
as artwork to a Danish thing ofama
[__] uh and a famous artist you said
no no a Danish artist oh and this person
pocketed large sums of money lent to him
by the museum and submitted empty frames
of his artwork uh wow and uh labeled it
take the Money and Run oh I remember
that yeah yeah art SC art what did you
guys think of it at that time recall
that please I thought it was great May
money take it run good job it's a good
business model anybody else I never
heard of that I'm not familiar with the
story basically it's one of those like
you know like uh somebody gets
commission to kind of so they they're
lent money in order to like create some
sort of like giant canvas this person
thinks that they're like a very very
edgy artist by giving back empty frames
like basically nothing on the Camas and
then they call it yeah Take the Money
and Run that is the art yeah that is the
art but you know obviously at the same
time in a very abstract way if yeah if
it creates conversation we're we're here
on the other side of the world talking
about like is it is it not art is that
not that's kind of like Banky right like
the thing just destroys itself yeah
basic that was Art though that yeah
that's art who are you to say what isn't
isn't art exactly it's objective go
ahead explain yourself no that's it
that's all I know
okay and that was like that was there
was some genius behind that cuz that was
planned to a point where like at an
auction you know there's like a real
time like there's an audience to it this
isn't just like scamming the person who
like lent you the money to for from the
museum this seems lazy well now that
particular artist has been ordered to
repay the museum after submitting these
empty oh [__] by an official court uhoh
he's in travel yeah roughly $49,500 was
loaned to him from the Museum's C offers
to recreate his work um and now he's got
to pay it back under court order how
much 40 something,
$49,000 damn imagine that so he has to
get the money and return is his new art
piece so he should do something cool as
[__] some of these art people dude are
funny huh does he do other art pieces I
mean he has to because like imagine like
you to even get that loan from a museum
you're probably already like in some way
yeah should probably just like tape a
banana to a canvas and send like
multiples of those you know I feel like
when you're the first to do anything
like that it's like all right [__] it
you got it just just make the banana
pink like he shouldn't have he shouldn't
have made it blank he should have just
rode on it take the money and run at
least it would have been some type of I
thought he could just write art like
like and then people would go cuz if
it's blank you're like I'm not going to
the [__] Museum blank but if it says
Take the Money and Run like that's like
an Instagram that's like a picturable
thing yeah yeah that's true and there's
a story behind it he could have now the
exhibition of this actually ran from
September 2021 to January 2022 and the
museum ultimately did hang the frames
but demanded that he repay the
commission so I mean in one weird sense
they did hang it up and it's again
sparked conversation so there's so they
came out on top there's an element of it
was still used if they used that [__] he
is not paying that money back yeah he
they used it that's ridiculous that's
true cuz the art someone can argue that
the art was the conversation around it
and that got way more conversation than
any piece probably would have gotten
that he painted well also technically it
was a
loan a loan initially like a advance
yeah I guess no like a loan I guess like
uh here borrow some money borrow some
money do something and then when the
museum reive his money back after like
the you know the uh the what's it called
the oh so
service it was a commission to do
something with the money to create
something yeah and then you know once
the Art Exhibit gets their money back I
guess so they didn't get their money
back I I don't know how museums work
dude museums are [__] scams dude yeah
dude museums are [__] scams just like
Airlines [__] Airlines and [__] museums
dude and I'm going to stand on that
they're good uh writeoffs
like you you put like let's say you put
your art in and then you'll be like or
let's say like you're rich right you
bought like a rembrand or whatever for
like 20 million or whatever right and
then you go um Smithsonian or you loan
it to the museum right yeah you loan it
to them so how does the money work on
that sense then as a write off so you're
donating them you go so the fee to borle
my art is 2 million a year or whatever
right that's my fee and then the uh
Museum goes that be income yes but you
know what I'm not going to charge you
this 2 million I'm going to donate that
fee and then they'll you know have the
art there and then people can come see
the Ram brand or whatever and then you
get a a personal income right off
business guy over here see you look like
a guy that would own a museum you kind
of do doesn't he uh more like the uh
metal trinket
Museum you know like mine I'm the bottle
cap Museum guy kind no you you could go
either way you could be very low class
or very high class yeah that's true like
Kanye homeless right right right like no
like Rick
Reuben you have VI yeah I just went to
the uh Getty Villa in Malibu and it's
like a pretty pal I love the gy it's
cool it's [__] cool but then there's
certain things that I was like what the
[__] is this and some of it is like they
have a bust of like a person and then on
the description this is what I had beef
with and it was like tons of them it was
like all across the Museum and it's some
guy's head and it says statue of man and
you're
like okay yeah and then the description
and the description is like 50 different
words saying this is a SC a sculpture of
a man in the Greek times is it a special
man no I said this like two weeks ago
did you and it's the same thing and I go
okay what's over here and then the other
one is that that was like excavated from
like an ancient time of course of course
that's the cool part but [__] make up
something dude sell me on something
right the next one is a girl and it says
a sculp a bust of a woman possibly like
Megan or something that's what the name
was and you're like who the [__] is
Megan dude but the issue I have with
that cuz I went to Greece and I did that
and like they made it in like 2018 I'm
like I came here to see ancient
[__] you know what I mean I came I flew
to Greece to let me see some old Greek
[__] yeah they like they that right it
was made recently so those ones were
like something something BC or ad which
is cool I like that right but also too
it's like ancient [__] [__] make up a
story about oh oh so yours were old ones
yeah oh that's [__] cool it's cool I
went to a Greek Museum and it literally
was like made like a year ago I'm like
dude what the [__] is this was it a good
looking horse it looked cool I'm not
going to
lie it [__] looks hard to make I I
respect it and then they have other
statues of like Hercules with like a
[__] you know a club and like a lion
and [__] you're like oh this is [__]
cool but then there's like a bust of a
guy it's just a bust of man and there's
like hundreds of them all across the
[__] the the Getty Villa and you're
like okay I think statues were so much
cooler back in the day cuz you had to
like like go like that now you just like
put it in a [__] in a thing and it
goes and a 3D printer and then it comes
out and it's perfect yeah so it's
there's no people back then though if
they were seeing the they'd be like yeah
I guess that's true we're like baring
seeing it we're out of
jobs or like the medieval books have you
seen those at the Getty that [__] is
crazy which one the Getty Center or the
Getty Villa they're like [__] made in
200 ad or some [__] like all ancient
right and you're just like what the [__]
this is what they used to read but it's
the actual it's the actual book oh
that's cool it's the actual yeah and
then they had the these like these
little tombs and the people were like
this [__] big dude their people are
tiny they were small why were they so
small just [__] Fooda nutrients bro
nutrients you ever been to the Army
museum in Paris no yeah and you see the
solders uniform and the shoulders are
literally like this W you're like holy
[__] and even the armor that goes around
them are like this what if they were
kids cuz like if they were 16-year-old
soldiers right yeah especially if they
they die with like 25 yeah and they
weren't drinking like [__] milk whole
milk the way we do now life you think
they were [__] yeah you think they were
having Barb elberg grade protein dude I
don't think so dude they're not those
those kids are definitely not hitting
their protein than you can say G any
time you want I can thank God I've been
wait that's the whole reason I came
today to get my
pass you got it buddy yes hey D dude I'm
good dude I'm good now I'll say it when
I get home or in the car the second I
close the door in the
car anybody got like a favorite museum
or like a piece that they've seen in a
museum I'd have to say that Napoleon's
War Museum in Paris was pretty freaking
sick that'd be tight um cuz you see like
the you see what things like the purpose
of what things are for instead of like a
abstract an idea like there's this one
where it's like a revolver but like
they're just stupid back then so it was
like a a imagine a 10-ft revolver where
you have a guy shooting and there's
another guy holding it like you're like
okay I kind of get the point but it's
cool to see how things evolved you know
versus like man or whatever yeah
sculpture of man you're like okay that's
fine fine but why is this here I got to
say I was pretty let down by the Mona
Lisa really it's so small huh there's
way crazier paintings around us and
especially the way that it's just
portrayed in the history books as a kid
your imagination is so wild about like
one of the most glorious [__]
paintings of all time you go there and
there's like 100 people and everybody's
trying to scramble to get to the front
you're like where's this thing and it's
like this small yeah it's like this big
behind like a [__] 3-in bulletproof
glass and it's a woman and she's just
like a six and you're like w six give
her six I'll give her dude I'll give
Mona six dude might be like a four I
think and that was like the hottest girl
of the time you're in Paris you're on
vacation a four is a six you always up
at
two that's maybe that's just her no
makeup you her no makeup different
outfit might was like maybe a huge like
very John marish at the time sweat pants
hair tie chill with no makeup on she got
a crazy forehead though yeah it looks
like she's balding huh maybe you look
around right they have those massive
paintings like the size of a wall and
it's like super grandiose and it's like
the royal family [__] going on in there
dog and like yeah there's like a lady
showing her [__] titty and it's like
grapes and [__] like it's crazy yeah I
think that was more like wow look at
that if I go back to the lou I'm going
back with roller
skates what's the Lou it's a museum yeah
in Paris it's [__] huge and if you're
just on foot you can't see everything in
one day oh really
SK no he can't oh you can't damn it he's
like dude I'm going back with a long
board I'm going to shred the loop
[__] you got to take like the Segways
away from the mop type people I think
they did the a mathematical calculation
if you spend like 5 seconds per picture
it's going to take at least 3 days for
real is that big it's like this sh like
that per like exhibit cuz there's like
huge Halls here there's huge halls there
there's huge halls there even more than
museums though what I like are like
castles and like I just saw one in
Scotland it was the coolest [__]
ever Castle you know you can buy one
dude and it's [__] crazy you could
get it for like half a mil damn isn't
that crazy a castle castle dude don't be
a puss still don't want one for a Las
Vegas price but what if you want
Chick-fil-A is there Chick-fil-A close
to the castle there's no Uber Eats out
there damn it I feel like if you pay
like a couple mil then you're getting a
castle close to the city oh but if you
pay like half a m you get a castle but
it's in the middle of nowhere no mo
though you got nothing but
sheep sold
separately ler 200 200,000 extra yeah
and that's just for the mind blown how
cheap it is I was like under a million
you can get a castle that pretty I went
I went to the castle it was called
Blackness castle and I I went to it um
and I was like uh I was like it was cool
but like it was for prisoners and I'm
like I wanted to see for prisoners yeah
I was like I want to see the do like
where see the ti [__] yeah where's the
[__] I went to the one and it was for
[__] prisoners I was like this is is
depressing yeah you went to the night
watch man you didn't even go to the the
Lannisters night was the one that was
the closest to me I was like
[__]